Pero en serio, todos decimos que odiamos esta basura,
la pregunta es si uno está dispuesto a hacer
un sacrificio personal para cambiarlo.
No me refiero a renunciar a la Internet,
me refiero a cambiar la forma de hacer clic,
porque hacer clic es un acto público.
Ya no es el caso,
que unas pocas élites poderosas
controlan todos los medios
y el resto de nosotros somos solo receptores pasivos.
Cada vez más, somos todos los medios de comunicación.
Solía pensar, oh, está bien, me visto,
me pongo mucho maquillaje,
voy de la televisión, hablo de la noticias.
Eso es un acto público de hacer los medios de comunicación.
Luego me voy a casa y navego por la web
y leo Twitter,
y eso es un acto privado de consumo de medios.
Quiero decir, claro que lo es, estoy en mi pijamas.
Error.
Todo lo que blogueamos, todo lo que tuiteamos,
y a todo a lo que hacemos clic
es un acto público de estar en los medios.
Somos los nuevos editores.
Nosotros decidimos lo que llama la atención
con base a lo que le damos atención.
Así es como funcionan los medios ahora.
Hay todos estos algoritmos ocultos que deciden
lo que se ve más y lo que todos vemos más
basados en lo que hacemos clic,
que a su vez da forma a toda nuestra cultura.
Tres de 5 estadounidenses piensan que tenemos
un grave problema de falta de civismo en nuestro país actualmente,
pero voy a suponer que, al menos, 3 de cada 5
estadounidenses están haciendo clic en el mismo insulto,
difundiendo el rumor que alimenta
los impulsos más repugnantes de nuestra sociedad.
En un panorama mediático cada vez más ruidoso,
el incentivo es hacer más ruido para ser oído,
y esa tiranía de lo escandaloso
alienta la tiranía de lo desagradable.
No tiene por qué ser así.
No tiene por qué.
Podemos cambiar el incentivo.
Para empezar, hay dos cosas que todos podemos hacer.
Primero, no aislarse cuando ven a alguien haciendo daño.
Si alguien es víctima de acoso en línea, ¡hagan algo!
Sean héroes. Esta es su oportunidad.
Hablen. Hablen. Sean buenas personas.
Ahoguen lo negativo con lo positivo.
Y en segundo lugar, dejemos de hacer clic
en el más bajo-común-denominador del botón que alimenta
al enlace señuelo.
Si no les gusta 'toda la programación
todo Kardashian 24/7',
tienen que dejar de hacer clic en las historias
sobre las fotos de los senos de Kim Kardashian.
Sé que lo hacen. (Aplausos)
Ud. también, al parecer.
De verdad, el mismo ejemplo:
si no les gustan los políticos que se andan insultando
dejen de hacer clic en las historias
acerca del tipo de un partido que insultó al del otro partido.
Hacer clic en un choque de trenes solo vierte gasolina.
Hacen que sea peor, el fuego se extiende.
Toda nuestra cultura se quema.
Si el que obtiene el mayor número de clics gana,
entonces tenemos que empezar a dar forma al mundo que queremos
con nuestros clics,
porque hacer clic es un acto público.
Entonces hagan clic en forma responsable. Gracias.
(Aplausos)